[MUSIC PLAYING]
-This is our third
of three panels.
And this one is on
public discourse,
how news, cinema, advertising
gets out to the public
and is shaped-- presumably to an
audience which is at least 50%
female-- and on the other
hand shaped mainly by men.
So the panel consists of
Mary Mills, Liza Johnson,
and Christine Matthews
and is moderated
by Kathleen Hall Jamieson.
Kathleen is a professor
at the Annenberg School
at the University
of Pennsylvania,
author and co-author of 16 books
mostly on political discourse
and politics.
She's also a founder of
factcheck.org and more recently
sidecheck.org in 2015.
And last night I
got to learn what
it's like to be an outsider at
a George Wallace rally, which
was fascinating.
So I'll turn it
over to Kathleen.
-Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Welcome back.
The premise of this panel
is that the popular culture,
including politics, shapes the
way in which we see each other.
And the talk in
those environments
and the visual images in
those environments matter.
We're privileged to have
a panel today of people
who are what I would call
custodians of that culture.
They understand it.
They've worked within it.
They felt the constraints of it.
They are trying to break out
of it, many times successfully.
I'd like to frame our discussion
by going back to the 1950s
and situate us permanently there
for about a minute and a half.
In the 1950s, the
scholarly community
recognized that televised
images over long periods of time
can cultivate our
view of reality,
that we can come
to see a world that
is far different from
the world we actually
experience by experiencing
the world of televised images.
And that body of
scholarship, produced largely
at the Annenberg School at the
University of Pennsylvania,
said that, for
example, when you're
a very high consumer
of television,
you are far more likely to think
that the world is crime-ridden
than it is and that your world
is crime-ridden than it is.
We replicated that
finding, finding
that when you watch high
amounts of local news,
you think the same
thing, in addition,
you're far more likely
to think that you're
going to be victim of a fire.
Now what that tells
us is ongoing exposure
to unquestioned
assumptions can ultimately
shape the way in which we think
and the way in which we speak
and potentially the
ways in which we act.
We also know from other research
that these kinds of images
can teach us how we should
function in situations.
And sometimes that
can be negative.
So, for example, you can
normalize perception of smoking
by having ongoing exposure of
both young men and young women
to people who are smoking in
video contexts, a finding we
just replicated on YouTube.
Well, we found
that when you look
at an ongoing basis--
seeing a lot of people--
and that is normative
in YouTube videos
about smoking-- a lot of
young people smoking often
in their bedrooms, often
with their friends--
you are more likely to think
that other people smoke
and your attitudes about
smoking are, as a result,
more likely to be positive.
So if we say that something as
basic as seeing other people
doing things on an ongoing
basis can shape something
as potentially
damaging as increasing
the likelihood of
smoking, you're
saying something which
is profoundly disturbing.
But we also know
that images that you
see in this kind of
environment can help expand
your world in positive ways.
How many of us saw
a different world
when we saw Julia
for the first time--
if we are of a certain age?
How many of us saw a
different kind of relationship
when we saw Will & Grace?
How many of us looked at
The Mary Tyler Moore Show
and saw the struggles that
some of our generation
were experiencing as we
were entering the workforce?
Those kinds of portrayals
expand our sense
of the available options.
And as we watch fictive
characters dealing with them
either tell us what kinds of
things work or don't work,
what might be
successful strategies
or failed strategies.
In the process, of course,
it's possible to model
a whole lot of dysfunction in
interpersonal relationships.
And as a result, we
can ask the question,
what does it do when
people we care about
and the people we
are are portrayed
in these kinds of venues?
I wrote a book in the mid-1990s
called Beyond the Double Bind--
Women in Leadership.
It hypothesized that
historically women
were placed in a situation in
which no matter what they did,
it was the wrong choice.
And I called them
double binds and said
that what we've essentially
accomplished as women
across time and as people who
have been oppressed by others
as a group across
time is found ways
to navigate out of those
socially constructed binds.
But we're still experiencing
the residue of them.
So very early women
were told, you literally
can't go into the academy
because women's brains
can't work because their
uteruses are functioning.
And so if your uterus is
functioning, your brain can't.
The women who
overcame that came out
of the science curricula
inside women's colleges
and they engaged in
experiments which showed,
for example, that a menstruating
woman can add and subtract
as well as a non-menstruating
woman, that a pregnant woman
can multiply as well as
a non-pregnant woman,
and interestingly enough,
she can do it just
as well as a man who is neither
menstruating nor pregnant.
That's what you call
a control group.
Now what is the residue?
The residue of that
is Donald Trump
suggesting that Megyn
Kelly is menstruating
when Megyn Kelly asks a
question about which Donald
Trump disapproves about the
ways in which he's cast women.
What it suggests
is that something
is going wrong hormonally,
and as a result,
her brain isn't functioning
as well as it should.
And well, she's
bleeding from wherever.
And as Carly Fiorina notably
said in another context,
we all understood exactly
what he was saying.
We also have a double bind
that I called silence shame.
That is, women weren't allowed
to move into the public sphere,
and if they did, they
were called whores.
As a result, women's
speech was substantially
speech that was not heard
outside the limited sphere
in which women were
able to operate.
Well, we ultimately
overcame that historically.
Many heroic women stood up.
Men of goodwill
stood up as well.
And as a result, women moved
into the public sphere.
The residue of that
silent shame double bind
is one in which people say
Hillary Clinton is shouting.
It's not appropriate to shout.
When you pair that
with a man engaging
in exactly the
same decibel level,
no one says that
man is shouting.
They say that man is forceful.
The residue of the double
bind is still being overcome.
The argument of the book
was we overcome the residue
by meta-communicating about it,
making people conscious of it.
That's part of what
we're doing today
as we move into all
of the other ways
in which individuals are
marginalized by a society that
needs help in reframing
its understanding of itself
and of others.
We saw it as well
with Hillary Clinton
when Hillary Clinton
pauses before she
laughs when responding to a
question that is unanticipated.
It was described as a cackle
by The New York Times.
Rudy Giuliani, also a
front running candidate
during that
election, would pause
before he would laugh in a way
that seemed a little eccentric
and no one called it a cackle.
We have a residue historically
of the ways in which we've
marginalized female speech
in the form of a vocabulary
to condemn women's discourse.
And there's no
comparable vocabulary
to condemn or even to
describe exactly the same kind
of behavior when
we find it in male.
Finally, there was a
third bind-- I actually
looked at five; I'm only
going to [INAUDIBLE] three--
called aging invisibility.
Women were led into
positions marginalized out
during the childbearing
years and then told
that they were too old just
as they were about to hit
their professional stride.
I call that aging invisibility.
Aging invisibility is
ultimately overcome
as women move into leadership
positions around the world--
Margaret Thatcher,
Indira Gandhi.
We move onto our Supreme
Court-- Sandra Day O'Connor
taking a lead there.
Women move into secretary
of state positions.
And what's ultimately the
residue that is still there?
You have a conservative
talk radio host who says,
do we really want to
watch Hillary Clinton get
old in front of
our eyes as she's
president of the United States?
My answer is, I'd
like to see that.
And with that, as
a transition, it
is my pleasure to introduce
our first panelist.
Mary Mills is the
Worldwide Director
of Strategic Intelligence.
Now, labeling matters.
Think about this label
for just a moment.
The Worldwide Director of
Strategic Intelligence,
is that not a powerful label?
My pleasure.
Mary, to turn the
panel over to you.
Thanks, Kathleen.
"Gender Fluidity
in Advertising."
I need to qualify that.
It's actually more appropriately
given this context,
it should be entitled
toward gender fluidity
in advertising because
it's a big claim.
And it's an optimistic one.
And it's picking up right
where Kathleen led us
in terms of the
positive influence
that advertising can have.
And that's what I want to
talk to you about today.
I'm going to show you some
examples of advertising
using men and women in
respectful and disrespectful
ways.
Some of it is our own work
from Saatchi & Saatchi.
Some of it is from
other agencies.
But I want to show you
how it mirrors who we are
and how we can use
it for better good.
First, a context.
So three things I need you
to understand about this.
When we say language in my
business in the advertising
game, it's words and pictures.
I want to talk about that
in a little more detail.
I want to talk about how we can
use advertising in a better way
that you might not
have anticipated.
As one of my kids
has on her bulletin
board on her desk, a
little poster that said,
if you talk to people the
way that advertising does,
they would punch
you in the face.
So that's my home life.
And my kids remind me
constantly that advertising
is an interruption.
It's not warranted.
It's not liked.
It messes up our lives.
And my agenda here is to shift
your perception of advertising,
that, in fact, it can do
some really decent things.
So first and foremost,
we talk about language.
It's words and pictures.
Words are just
part of the story.
And I don't even want to
put a number on whether it's
half or a quarter or a third.
It's two very different ways
of communicating messaging.
Just the way this is.
One is art.
And one says, "This is art."
They do two very different jobs.
We have two very different
jobs within the agency
as art director and writer,
but they work together
on everything.
So even an art
director and writer
would work on a radio script.
They would work on a
print ad, whether or not
there is any art
direction involved.
It's two ways of
thinking of things, two
ways of getting the idea right.
Public discourse-- how
do I fit into this panel
here in terms of how we
affect views and beliefs
in the public discourse?
Broadly, historically,
movies would be considered
entertainment and escape.
Speeches are about
visions, common rhetoric,
inspiring people to take
action at a certain time.
And ads are about us
selling you stuff.
So it seems like we're the
poor cousin on all this.
But what I want to talk
to you about is, given
the proliferation
of advertising,
the amount of
money that's spent,
the ubiquity of advertising,
and the global sharing
of advertising, it has a
power that we're just starting
to realize and tap into.
Finally, one of the things
that I think advertising can do
is make it normal.
Let me explain that a bit.
For 100 years, we've been
thinking about advertising
as helping you buy
products and services.
The original example
is Sunkist Oranges.
There was a surplus of
fruit, perishable product.
California marketers
said, can you help us?
We don't know what
to do with this.
We're going to lose a fortune.
Ad team came together and
said, let's talk about orange
juice for breakfast.
Fast forward 100 years,
orange juice for breakfast
is a very common thing.
Little did you know
that that was an ad
guy that got you into that.
Same for bacon.
Same for coffee.
A lot of the habits
that we currently enjoy
came from an
advertising guy's idea.
This might be appropriate.
Now nobody made you do that.
It obviously fit the
context of what people
were interested in at the time.
But we had a role
in help shaping it.
So 100 years later, we've
come to realize, hey,
if we can help people understand
why it's important to drink
orange juice or why it's
important to save their money
or why it's important to have
insurance or brush their teeth,
why can't we help people
understand how to view women,
how to view men, how to treat
each other more respectfully?
Why can't we?
It's a very powerful medium.
So let's look at
way back in the day.
This was before I
got into advertising.
and this is in the 70s
when cigarette advertising,
just as an example, early
days targeted by gender.
It was very clear.
Men were in car ads.
Women were in soap ads.
And one of the first
examples of, well, here's
a category where actually,
hey, wait a minute,
both men and women use
it the same amount.
Let's figure out how to do this.
So Marlboro Man is one of
the most iconic cigarette
advertising campaigns
in the world.
I'm not condoning
smoking cigarettes,
just looking at this as an ad.
Here is steely gazed, rugged
jaw, rough guy, very cool.
He smokes cigarettes.
Let's do one for women.
So they make the
cigarette slimmer.
And they have her semi-clothed.
And they have her
in a sassy position.
Fast forward, whether
or not this appealed
to women who smoked
or not, Marlboro's
the only one that's
still in existence.
And most women I know
who smoked at the time
liked Marlboro because
they thought it was cool.
And it's too easy to say it was
because men did the advertising
or because clients wanted
it that way-- there
were very strict ways
in terms of, well,
we're going to do
a women's version,
this is what it
should look like.
So that's a theme
I'm going to talk
to you about as we go through.
Role ricochet.
What I mean by that is
throughout these categories--
as I show you some examples
of advertising that
are done for women or for men
or have women saying things
that men used to say or men
saying things that you used
to say, I call that a ricochet.
It was made up for
this conference.
So you can be proud to say,
if it gets in to be a meme,
you can say you
heard it here first.
It's a ricochet.
And it influences each other.
And when we do that,
an effect happens.
And it makes it better
going back the other side.
This is all, in a way,
building the story of how
we'll get to gender fluidity.
So here are some categories
of food advertising.
Probably the most conservative
to the least conservative
in terms of the categories
we're going to talk about.
Let's look at food.
Special K is a resolutions ad.
That was in Canada in 2008.
Some of the ads I'm
going to show you
are a little bit dated,
but they broke through
and did an extraordinary thing.
Watch this.
-This year I will not--
-Freak out if I gain two pounds.
-I will stop asking--
-Do I look fat in this?
-Do I look fat?
-I will learn to
appreciate my body.
-I will not let my dress size--
-Determine my self-worth.
-That's not that long ago,
but that broke through.
That was the first time we put
in very burly, rugged men's
mouths things that
women say all the time.
We were used to women talking
about their bodies that way.
When we showed women
that men saying it,
they kind of went,
oh, yeah, sort of,
yeah, let's not do that so much.
Very successful.
It helped shape us stop
saying stuff like that.
Stop saying "I have
my mother's thighs.
I just have to live with it."
Men don't talk that way.
Why should we?
I'm going to show
you two chocolate
commercials-- one designed for
women and one designed for men.
I don't know why
women have me time
and men don't seem to
use that expression.
I don't know if it's a
good thing or a bad thing.
But this was an ad designed
around that for Dove Chocolate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Dove Pure Silk Chocolate, now
with the tantalizing crunch
of almond.
My moment, my Dove.
-My time.
Very passive.
Our data guys will tell you
that somewhere along the line
someone did a study that
said women would prefer
to have chocolate than sex.
So some bright one
said, well, this
is how they see chocolate then.
It's all terribly sexy
and terribly sensual
and terribly lovely.
Some women liked
it, but not all.
Look at this.
And by contrast, this was
done by our office in the UK.
Do you know this one?
[MUSIC - PHIL COLLINS, "IN THE
AIR TONIGHT"]
With all due respect
to our data people,
there is no amount of
data that ever would
have got you to that idea.
Advertising has a
distinct role in some
of our creative enterprises
that it can transform,
the creative process
can transform the world.
I truly believe that.
What happened here?
Huge success for Cadbury.
I actually got it back
in the books big time.
You know, health food, we didn't
want to eat chocolate so much,
whatever.
Just a huge spike.
But the more interesting
things is women
liked it just as much as men.
The problem we have is
when we think in gender,
we get into trouble.
And when we listen to
the superficial stories
that we hear, well, they
like it better than sex,
so that's where
it's going to be.
That's way sexier,
a gorilla on drums.
Nothing was ever said.
He just played drums.
When you see it in its
full 90-second version,
it's absolutely magnificent.
Please look at it.
But it was hugely successful.
And women loved it.
We need to learn to understand
better what we share,
not what makes us different.
Oh, parenting.
This is a very personal thing
for me because I'm a parent.
And some of the things
that we do to ads to moms
make me cringe.
We just finished a global study
of 8,000 moms around the world.
And over half of them-- so
let's say between the ages of 15
and up, 70% of those
women are moms.
That's 2 billion
moms in the world
think that we have an
outdated view of them.
So do the math.
Not only is it offensive,
but look at how much money
we're wasting.
How dumb is that?
Next year, we're
going to be doing men,
and I swear we're going
to get the same result.
So there's something
very wrong with the way
that we're speaking
to moms in particular.
Women have some ways of being
different and fun and exciting.
You become a mom,
you're one-dimensional.
You're a caregiver.
And the problem is every
ad that we've put out
has talked about mom is
when busy moms, targets are
busy moms caring for your kids.
It's too one-dimensional.
And younger moms, in particular,
saying, that's not me.
You're talking to my mom.
You don't get me.
Here's how they gave us a clue
of how we could talk to them.
So on the far, there's carer.
And the green bar is how much
I'd like to do that role more.
And the white bar is how
much I'd like to do it less.
So when we reflect
moms in ads, they say,
could you reflect a little less
on the care and a little more
on all the other
roles that they would
love to play-- a safe house,
a coach, a fan, a playmate,
a rule breaker, a hero.
Can't mom have some of
the fun some of the time?
This is an example of the kind
of work that they object to.
Look what mom does.
Look what the man--
the dad and the kid do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So dad and daughter have this
fabulous routine, a ritual.
They do the candy.
They do the dance.
What is mom?
Unpacking the groceries.
Can't she be the fun one?
Can't she be the rule breaker?
Can't she be eating candy
before dinner sometimes?
Of course she can.
-Hi.
I'm a dad mom.
That means while my wife works,
I'm at home being awesome.
Tide Boost is my Tide.
What's yours?
-A dad mom?
This makes me insane.
If a man is at home doing
helpful parenting chores,
he's a dad mom.
So when I go to
work am I a mom dad?
We did that.
That was our New York office.
We did that last year.
Thankfully, we redeemed
ourselves with this one.
-May I help you with something?
-Yes.
Uh, I'm-- I'm looking for the,
uh-- they go on the, you know--
-For the breast pump?
-Huh?
-First kid?
-Come on, bro.
-Oh, hey, can you grab me a
couple boxes of breast shields?
-Second kid.
Live, learn, and get Luvs.
-You know, just a much
more authentic story.
Men object to advertising
as well, as I said.
And the biggest
objection they have is
stop making us look so stupid.
Any time we're trying to do
something like parenting,
we look stupid.
He might have looked
a little awkward,
but it was because he
was a first-time parent,
not because he was a man.
And the second time, nailed it.
Yeah, done.
I mean, he's got a whole
litany on hemorrhoid cream
after that that I cut
for the interest of time.
But that's a much better example
of how we can show parents
in our work.
Alcoholic beverages.
Now isn't that just the way
women like to drink their beer?
This is Canadian too.
I'm so embarrassed.
Note the shade of pink.
We have pink beer, and
we have chartreuse beer.
That's not that long ago.
2012.
What's the matter with you guys?
If you ever sat down and had
a conversation with a woman
when she was drinking beer, you
would know how silly that was.
But again, Ben
mentioned something
earlier about focus groups.
If you're in a situation
and you ask them a question,
they'll tell you the
answer you're looking for.
You have to be really careful
how you ask the question
and how you do it if
you want the truth.
This is just silly.
I mean, that lasted
about two weeks,
and that's gone, thankfully.
Oh.
Again, I just take
this so personally
because I like scotch.
And I was very proud of Diageo.
We do that.
I was very proud of Diageo.
They said we have a
women's initiative.
We've realized that women
drink a lot of alcohol.
More lately, huh, Kathleen?
And here we are.
So they've expanded the
repertoire to include women.
So we have Jude Law
having a scotch moment,
enjoying a moment of success,
perhaps just finishing a film.
And then we women
playing superhero.
I mean, why?
Why can't we have
a successful moment
that looks more appropriate
and more relaxed and more
like a scotch moment?
Understand when I
drink scotch, it's
not when I put my cape
on and do Wonder Woman.
The redeeming
feature for Diageo,
and I will give them this,
this is important to me
because-- you can't see that.
It may be in the small type.
But when Diageo first began
the unisex brand project,
there were no
women on the board.
Now five of its 11
directors are women.
I'm happy about that.
It's not easy, this game
that we're in, advertising.
We don't always get it right.
That's right.
That's a good outcome.
They'll get it better.
I trust they will.
Technology.
You would think these
leading-edge guys, particularly
Apple, would be we're so
forefront, we're so young,
we'll know all this.
Just last year they could have
had a really wonderful moment
for women, but
instead they launched
a new phone that's pink.
It's a nice phone.
I can forgive them for that.
The worst was their
new app, though,
that can adjust photography.
And they demonstrated
it on a woman.
And they said, look what this
does for resting bitch face.
And they did the
app that went up.
Stop laughing so hard.
So they showed this app
that made her smile.
So see, you can correct even
a woman who doesn't smile.
Stop telling us to smile
and just let us be.
I was disappointed in Apple.
Fitness.
More progressive,
much more progressive.
I have to introduce this
idea here now because it's
the adoption curve.
If you talk in advertising
about an idea that's
before its time, innovators and
early adopters, it will fail.
It will not get
into the mainstream.
You will get a tipping point.
So movies can do this.
Movies can be in the
innovators and early adopters
and get infiltrated
into culture.
We can't.
We got to cross the chasm
and get into early adopters.
I want to show you an example
of an ad from the early days
that I think is really
a shame it was too soon.
-If you let me play--
-If you let me play sports--
-I would like myself more.
-I would have more
self-confidence.
-If you let me play sports.
-If you let me play.
-I will be 60% less likely
to get breast cancer.
-I will suffer less depression.
-If you let me play sports.
-I will be more likely to
leave a man who beats me.
-If you let me play.
-I'll be less likely to get
pregnant before I want to.
-I will learn.
-I will learn what it
means to be strong.
-To be strong.
-If you let me play.
-Play sports.
-If you let me play sports.
-That ad changed the
trajectory of my career.
When I saw that, I knew what
I wanted to do in advertising.
It wasn't just to sell
toothpaste and life insurance
and alcoholic beverages.
I wanted to change the world.
I loved it.
And I was so excited.
And it was 1995.
And it just, mmm.
I mean, there were facts,
medical, scientific facts
that proved why it's better
to let women play sports.
It was too soon.
It was just too soon.
So happily, Nike
picked up the pace
and now they're doing
work for Under Armour
and there are a number
of other fitness brands
are doing magnificent work.
But it was just too soon.
So that's why the timing
for us is very important.
Always, "Like a girl."
I think you're
familiar with this.
A very simple idea.
-Show me what it looks
like to run like a girl.
-Oh, my hair.
Oh my god.
-Show me what it looks
like to fight like a girl.
-Throw like a girl.
-Show me what it looks
like to run like a girl.
-Throw like a girl.
What does it mean to you
when I say "run like a girl"?
-It means run fast as you can.
-Such a simple idea and such a
wonderful, wonderful campaign.
And you'll notice that
there's no product in there,
but it did extraordinary
things for P&G and for Always
because people are wanting to
know what do you stand for?
Why are you on this planet?
It's not just to sell
me stuff, but you better
stand for something
that's important to me.
Brilliant job.
Absolutely brilliant
job for them.
UK-- "This Girl Can."
Some wonderful images.
"I don't swim because
I hate my body.
It's because I love my body."
Really wonderful work
around the world.
Fashion.
Last but not least,
fashion you can
expect to be at the
forefront because they really
are the leading edge.
They don't have to appeal
to the mainstream--
that grid that I showed you--
like the rest of our products
do.
They can be a
little leading edge,
and then it trickles through.
Look at this wonderful thing.
I'm on it.
Thank you.
That's Jaden Smith
on the other side.
I just love this ad.
It's just delightful.
He's wearing a skirt.
Happy as a clam.
He looks fabulous.
He looks really cool.
He's not saying anything other
than I love wearing this.
Whether gender is identity
or gender is performance,
this is an absolutely delightful
way of looking at things,
and going, cool.
And last but not least,
this is an example to me
of gender fluidity
in advertising.
It's from Asia.
Sorry, Old Spice.
I forgot about this one.
This is from another
planet altogether.
Old Spice did some work
where they objectified
men the way women used to be
objectified in Budweiser ads,
but they made it funny.
They took the sting out of it.
I still have some questions.
If you had a woman put in the
same position where they said,
look at your girlfriend,
now look at me.
Look at your girlfriend,
now look at me,
we would be very upset.
But they did it with
guys, and it was funny.
And it took the sting out of it.
The jury's still
out on that one.
Last but not least,
look at this from Japan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So many extraordinary
metaphors in that.
The tag line in the
end there, given
I think is a very
powerful story line
is, makeup can make
anybody look cute.
Male, female, who cares?
Just an absolutely
delightful piece of work.
What we want-- listen.
Ask the right
questions, but listen.
I mean, really listen.
Get to know people.
The way we do better
work is to actually
talk to them one on one.
We call it exploring.
We live with them.
What's important to them,
what do they care about.
It's absolutely critical for us.
We get on to the data at one
point, but we've got to listen.
And that means
close up one on one.
Be authentic.
Understand the experience.
What is the scotch
drinking experience?
What is the beer
Don't just put a woman
slapped on it and think,
well, she might like this
because she likes pink.
I mean, that's so old.
And finally, target the
experience, not the gender.
We are so over targeting gender.
It's just not even appropriate.
It doesn't work.
And happily, the younger
guys coming up-- god
bless our millennials--
they want far more equality
between men and women.
So I think the future is bright.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you, Mary.
We're now going to transition
to Christine Matthews.
And again, I want you to take a
look at the title-- President.
The reason I'm featuring
titles is 30 years ago
you would not have been able to
find many women who could carry
these kinds of
titles and who then
did work commensurate with the
title to help change the way
in which we view the world.
It's my pleasure to introduce
Christine Matthews, President
of Bellwether Research.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you.
This has been an amazing event.
I've learned so much.
Last night, I was at the
wonderful comedy event.
Laughed so loud.
LOL, or lots of love.
And I was mostly just
happy that I knew the hip
words that Aparna put up there,
especially Netflix and chill.
Because I have a high
school daughter and it's
good to know the code.
So anyway, last
night, I got back
to my hotel room
a little bit late.
I tuned into the
Republican debate.
So I had missed the
discussion about the size
of Donald Trump's man parts.
For the most part, when except
for probably when John Kasich
was talking, I had to put it
on mute and just follow along
on Twitter because
I just couldn't.
But I find that it's pretty
rich that Donald Trump, when
asked about Hillary Clinton
being late to the debate stage
because she had
to take a bathroom
break-- he found that so
disgusting that he couldn't
even talk about it, yet he was
gifting us with the sharing
details about his endowments.
So if Donald Trump hadn't
brought the ridiculous train
wreck that he has brought to
the Republican primary election,
I think we'd be talking about
the role language and gender
and politics as something
that has become a little bit
less overt but is still
persistent and pernicious.
But nothing about Donald Trump
and what he says is subtle.
So I will include some
of his charming comments
as I look at the language
surrounding women candidates,
women office holders.
First, let's just take a
look at the lay of the land.
This is something I know
intuitively but not everybody
in the room may know, which
is women are obviously
very under-represented.
They're 19% of Congress, roughly
25% statewide office holders
or in the state legislature,
yet they are 53% of all voters.
There are particularly few
Republican women in Congress.
So you can see-- and this
data comes from the Center
for American Women in
Politics out of Rutgers,
which is a wonderful, valuable
source of information on all
this kind of information.
So we've got 62 Democratic
women in the House,
22 Republican women, 14
Democratic women US senators
and six Republican women.
So there's lots of
reasons-- including
the pipeline, funding-- for
the lack of Republican Women.
One of the other
reasons is they just
have a really difficult time
getting out of primaries.
And they're about 20 points
less likely to get out
of their primary than
a Democratic woman is
to get out of her primary.
One thing is true, Republican
primary electorates
are majority male.
Democratic primary electorates
tend to be majority female.
That may have one
thing to do with it.
But in 2012, for example,
57% of Republican women
lost their primaries compared
to 38% of Democratic women.
In 2014, it was slightly better,
but Republican women, again,
were 20 points less likely to
come out of their primaries.
So we're getting
clogged up there.
There are many reasons for
this lack of political parity.
One thing that we're
obviously examining today
is how language
plays a role in it.
So one thing I want to talk
about is what's in a name.
And thinking back to 2008,
both Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama were US senators when
they ran for president.
But a study found that Senator
Clinton was four times as
likely to be called by her first
name than was Senator Obama.
So her title was dropped
and she was just referred to
as Hillary or Hillary Clinton.
Male anchors, male
reporters were
more likely than female
anchors or female broadcasters
to drop her title.
So I really like that
Kathleen emphasized the title.
Because what happens
is titles infer status.
They infer power.
And for women candidates,
that title gets dropped.
I've done a lot of focus
groups, a lot of research.
One thing that I learned from
doing focus group with swing
women-- we were imagining
a different scenario,
but a debate where
you had Hillary
Clinton as a Democratic nominee
and a Republican nominee.
And we asked, what
would be the best way
to refer to Hillary Clinton?
What if somebody
called her Hillary?
And the women didn't
like it at all.
They felt absolutely
she should be referred
to as Secretary Clinton.
I haven't watched the
Democratic debates.
I've seen clips.
I think that's how
Bernie Sanders refers
to her, as Secretary Clinton.
So either that's
second nature or he's
also seen some data
that says this is really
what you need to do.
Back in 2014, we were involved
in pretty much every US Senate
race where there was
a woman candidate
either on the Republican
side or the Democratic side.
So in North Carolina,
speaker of the house
Thom Tillis was running against
the incumbent US Senator Kay
Hagan.
And in a debate, she referred
to him as Speaker Tillis.
He called her Kay.
And there was a big backlash.
And his point was I would
prefer that you call me Thom.
If you were Bob Hagan, I
would've called you Bob.
But it was just unseemly.
And there was a backlash
and seen as disrespectful
that he called her Kay.
And you can see, again,
candidates may brand themselves
using their first name.
Carly for President.
Jeb!
2016.
But that's something
you have to do.
Particularly, if you're a
man running against a woman,
you should never refer
to her by her first name.
You should always
include the title.
This is a really
interesting study.
Speaking of titles
and associations,
a new study out of Vanderbilt
done by an assistant professor
of political science there.
And this was done in Florida.
They had a random
sample of respondents.
And they showed these
images of men and women
in professional attire.
And what happened was the words
most associated with the men
were president and
executive and for the women
it was assistant or aide.
And she found that
regardless of some--
she had done some prescreening
questions about likelihood
to vote for a woman candidate.
Even among those who said,
yeah, I'm very open, absolutely
ready and likely to vote
for a woman candidate--
if they were more likely to
associate words like assistant
or aide to the woman
rather than the man,
it had an impact on
their vote behavior.
So this is a form
of hidden bias.
I've had women
members of Congress
tell me they've
had instances where
they've gotten into
the member elevator
and they've been told to get
out because they're staff.
Or they've been on
the floor of Congress
and have been
instructed to leave
because staff's not allowed.
So there's a lot of hidden bias.
And I think it's important
to recognize that.
So of course we have to
have some Donald Trump-isms.
This is actually rather mild
compared to many of the things
Donald Trump says.
But clearly he really
cannot handle smart women.
And so this was a tweet.
He loves to be on the Twitter.
And he said, "I just
realized that if you listen
to Carly Fiorina for more
than 10 minutes straight,
you develop a massive headache.
She has zero chance!"
So what he's saying is her voice
is irritating, it's grating.
He said the exact same thing
about Hillary Clinton's voice,
that it gave him a headache.
"She's so theatrical.
And her voice just
gives me a headache."
So the one thing Donald
Trump did tell The New York
Times that he wouldn't
say about Carly Fiorina
is he did say he would
not call her honey.
So you got that.
This is one of
those things where
women's voices are discussed.
They become something
that is other.
And the journalist Bob
Woodward, for example,
criticized Hillary Clinton
for shouting too much.
He said there's something
very unrelaxed about the way
she communicates, and that
she's not doing better
because she shouts too much.
And again, Kathleen, I
think you addressed that.
In fact, I'll have
a couple of points
that you addressed,
that a woman has
a very narrow bandwidth
in which you're
able to talk and project.
And if you think about it,
you're at a gigantic rally.
You're going to have to
raise your voice, right?
As opposed to speaking to
a small group of people.
Again, so women are
criticized for their voices.
They give people headaches
or they're too screechy
or they're too loud.
And this was the iconic moment.
This really was.
And Kathleen, again,
referred to it.
I think this was Carly Fiorina's
best moment of the campaign.
So she was asked about Donald
Trump in Rolling Stone who
said, "Look at that face.
Would anybody vote for that?
Can you imagine that, the
face of our next president?"
And so he tried to pretend that
he was meaning-- I don't even
know what you could
possibly mean by that--
but he was trying to
pretend it was her persona.
So Jake Tapper
asked Ms. Fiorina,
how do you feel about that?
And she said, I think women all
over this country heard very
clearly what Mr. Trump said.
And then she dropped the
mic, because it was great.
And it was really the
only time I have ever
seen shame or embarrassment
on Donald Trump's face.
Really, he did blush a little.
And then he
stammered, oh, I think
she has a beautiful face,
because he doesn't even
know what to say.
So that gets to the
attractiveness predicament.
And I think Kathleen has
obviously written books.
It's the double bind.
But the attractiveness
predicament
is a really big issue.
So we did a ton of focus
groups, a ton of research
around the US Senate
races in 2014.
And as I said, we were
involved in almost every one
that had a woman candidate
on either side of the aisle.
So in this case, this
was really unfortunate,
and we were kind of horrified.
Party spokesperson called
the US Senate candidate
from Kentucky "an empty dress
who babbles incoherently."
So can you ever imagine
it being said about a man
that he babbles incoherently?
No.
What's interesting,
though, is appearance
is not only a point of
discussion, observation,
criticism for men
of women candidates,
women also criticize other
women based on appearance.
It has to do with relatability.
In Georgia, for example,
I did focus groups.
And you may recall
that Michelle Nunn
was a candidate for US Senate.
She's smart, accomplished,
seems like a wonderful person.
Some of the comments
in the focus groups,
though, were-- she looks
like-- and you guys will
find this ironic--
a liberal college
professor from the Northeast.
So what they were saying
is she's not ratable to us
here in Georgia.
I can't relate to her.
She's other.
She's different.
I don't know.
In Louisiana, we were
doing focus groups.
And one of the participants--
who I did not enjoy at all--
said about the incoming
US senator, wow,
she's really gotten old and fat.
And he, of course, was old
and fat, but never mind.
And he just said it like it was
some kind of great indictment
and great insight on his part.
So that was just
really annoying.
So there's how we look,
there's how we talk, oh,
and how we laugh.
So we are supposed to smile,
but we're not supposed
to laugh too big or too loud.
This was a comment
on social media.
"Hillary's cackle alone
is enough to keep her
off the world stage."
So cackle is something
a witch does, right?
And a witch rhymes with-- right?
And can you imagine a US
president who cackles?
No, I think that is actually
one of the most damaging words--
cackle.
I did a little Google search.
Lots of YouTube videos, mix-ups
of Hillary Clinton's cackle.
And I think that's
actually very damaging.
So then, of course,
women have to be smart,
but they also have
to be likable.
So they have to be smart.
They have to be competent.
They have to be not
too this, not too that.
And this as important to
women as it is to men.
So this is a quote
from a big donor
who had given to Barack Obama.
"It's not that I don't
think she's competent."
This is about Hillary
Clinton. "She's competent.
She's just hard to like."
So this is somebody
who's saying why
he's withholding making
a donation to Hillary
Clinton when he supported
Barack Obama in 2008 and 2012.
"She's just not likable."
And this is about
Carly Fiorina, and this
is a woman saying it actually.
And the thing
about Carly Fiorina
is I really think she
overperformed in the debates.
Her command of facts and her
ability to talk policy, I think
was really impressive.
So then she was criticized
for not smiling enough.
So she had to really
work on relatability.
And this was a woman saying
there's a hardness in how
she speaks and carries herself.
Social media can be brutal.
The words are OK, but look at
this image of Carly Fiorina
as a little girl in
pink running a company.
And the Democratic National
Committee did this.
On social media, it
can be very brutal.
Hashtag,
#wordsthatdon'tdescribeHillary.
An analysis of 12,000 tweets
was done by two PhD students.
1 in 12 comments was
about her appearance.
For men, in a sexual
way, and for women,
about likability
and relatability.
Traditional media
isn't perfect either.
A reporter told me that
the original headline
read "Gloria Steinem and
Madeline Albright Scold Young
Women Backing Bernie Sanders."
They got a little backlash.
They changed it to "rebuke."
Now scold is a word-- you may be
familiar with the Women's Media
Center.
They have something
called Name It.
Change It.
And they had a glossary
of words that they
recommended the media not
use because they were sexist.
Scold was one of them.
I don't know if you've heard
of the Hillary Rodham Clinton
super-volunteers.
These are words that
they have decided
are sexist surrounding
Hillary Clinton.
I think this goes
a little too far.
I think it's a good
point of discussion.
I think out of-- well,
it says "our of touch"--
but out of touch,
represents the past,
I don't see that as overly
sexist, but they do.
And they say they're watching.
Finally, just to wrap
up, I have done some work
with this great project.
It's a collaboration,
a nonpartisan project
of the Center for American Women
in Politics in the Barbara Lee
Family Foundation to
track, analyze, eliminate
gender dynamics in the
2016 presidential election.
So not that they'll
have anything to do,
but you can find them on
Facebook and on Twitter
under Gender Watch 2016.
And I highly recommend them.
They've written some
interesting things.
I've done some things with them.
And they're calling it
out, which is fascinating.
-Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Mary, they've spent
billions of dollars.
These are incredibly
talented people.
They have all the
research in the world.
They charge their clients
a whole lot of money.
Why did it take them so long
to get any of this right?
-It's hard.
First and foremost,
it's too easy
to either blame our clients or
blame that most of the writers
and the actors in the
early days were men.
It comes back to the
point of listening.
I am not the woman that we
target more often than not.
All my assumptions and
biases when I walk into work
and I write a brief or I
train a group or I teach them,
I have to put them in check.
It's really hard to do.
Most clients look at the work
that we do, and go, yeah,
my wife would love that.
That's a great ad.
Stop that behavior.
It's such ingrained
human behavior.
But if we listen, if we
ask the right questions,
and truly, truly engage the
audience with whom we'd like
to communicate, magic happens.
It's just obviously we
don't do it often enough.
It's too bad.
Actually, North America,
we're not great at it.
We're better at it in the UK.
We're better at it in Asia.
Intuitively, they seem
to understand-- I mean,
those are the guys
that did the gorilla.
They understand guys.
They didn't have to do
focus groups for it.
We're getting better,
but yeah, it's shocking.
I think now that we have data to
show how much money is wasted,
they may pay attention to that.
-Please tell us who you are
and frame your question.
-Hi.
My name is Globiana.
I'm a writer.
It's interesting to
me now that you're
talking about what's not said.
I wrote down a
whole list of words
that I heard in
conjunction with images
that I see in news, either in
print or with the voiceover.
It doesn't really matter.
And so I see pictures of
large groups of people,
insurrectionists they're called,
peacekeepers, demonstrators,
sunis, climate change experts,
rebels, world leaders, pirates,
Iraqis, and it goes on.
When I look at the picture,
phenotypically what I see
is men.
That's the one word that I never
hear is they're not called men.
When women are involved-- oh,
yes, remember Arab Spring?
There were women, and boy,
did they make a point of that.
Of course, the Democratic
primaries, we had the LPGA.
-And to whom would you like
to phrase the question?
-The question is-- I don't care.
It's just that it scares me.
And I want to know
if you people have
any sense of what's going on.
Why is this happening, I guess?
It scares me.
-Do you see it as happening?
And if so, why?
-Good question.
-Just on the whole
pronoun thing,
what is the "it" that is said
to be happening, perhaps,
may be happening?
-I'm not sure I understand.
-Leaving out the word men.
Refusing to say the word
men when what we see is men.
-I don't know if this really
addresses your question,
but as a person who
does a job who is also
a woman, every time I am
in public, people say,
oh, what's it like to
be a woman director?
And I often think what
it would be like-- I even
have a plan that I would
like to do this with some
of my male colleagues some
time that we can all do press
together so that they
can ask those guys like,
so how is it being
a man director?
And I do think that the
legion of the unmarked terms
of masculinity is
systematically present because
of the patriarchy.
And I think that is
true and that we just
have to continue working
against that by both marking
all these invisible
terms of dominance,
like masculinity and whiteness,
whenever we can and just do
that together as collectively
and systematically as possible.
-Thank you.
Next question.
Please tell us who you are
and frame your question.
-Hi.
My name is Sally.
I'm a student at Bridgewater
State University.
And I'm doing a project
on discrimination
against female producers.
And my question is
to Liza Johnson.
What are your thoughts
on discrimination
against female directors
in major film industries?
And what advice would you give
to upcoming female producers
or aspiring female producers?
-And can I ask
you, are you asking
me to make a distinction
between directors and producers?
Are you speaking
more collectively
about women who do executive
upper level jobs in filmmaking?
-I'm going to say females
who are in the film studios.
-OK.
Yeah.
Well, I think there's
interesting new data that I
would like to know more about.
Other people here might
know more than I do.
But I think the data
has been very clear
that hiring practices in
film companies, studios,
and independent projects are
systematically not weighted
in favor of women
or people of color.
And I think that's kind of
just proven by the data.
So my opinion about it
is not that important.
When it is encountered, I think
it is mostly unconscious, which
doesn't make it unsystematic.
But I've never had an experience
where there's a Lex Luthor
figure being like, I
don't know, little lady,
I don't think you can do this.
So in the absence of an
evil villain character
implementing racist
and sexist practices,
it doesn't mean that
they don't exist.
They clearly do.
And I think that I
don't really know
what to do about it
besides all of us
just keep working
as hard as we can
and maybe take an interest
in the work that's being done
by the EEOC and by the ACLU.
-Same question for Christine
and Mary in their own fields.
-So what would be the corollary
in my field, a discrimination
against women
candidates or women
-Women consultants who manage
campaigns and do polling.
-Yeah.
-Run firms.
-We've talked about this.
It's still an old boys' network.
And one of my companies
is called Burning Glass
Consulting.
I have two female partners.
We have only female employees.
And the idea is that
in an all-female firm
different things are seen,
different perspectives
are given.
And too often there's
not a woman at the table.
And what men think
is-- for example,
this happens not
only in advertising,
but in political campaigns.
So if you got a bunch of male
consultants around the table
and they're imagining, how
do we reach women voters?
So they put them in the kitchen.
And this happens on
both sides of the aisle.
This was something we tested in
some panel research that I did.
So the idea from the men is the
women are going to sit around
the table in the
kitchen and they're
going to talk about the
political candidate.
And every woman just
really reacted strongly.
Like, really, that's how
they're imagining us?
In the kitchen?
And that's the
kind of thing that
happens when there aren't
women at the table.
It's still kind of tough.
I don't know that
I can say, oh, I've
seen so much overt
discrimination.
I think it's maybe we're
just not thought of
to be included or
brought to the table.
And the other
thing that happens,
honestly, is when you have
a family and you have kids,
it becomes difficult with all
the demands that are made.
And so a lot of women I think
opt out at a certain point
and singularly focus
not very balanced.
Men continue.
-Mary?
-I guess the advice I would
give you-- is it there?
Yes, it is.
You need to be resilient.
You need to be thick-skinned.
And yes, we do work harder
than our male counterparts.
And that's still there.
I wouldn't trade it.
I still love the
career that I've had.
And I'm still enjoying it.
I'm surprised I'm still there.
I've been there 30 plus years.
Yeah, you can do it,
but it's not easy.
Find a mentor, someone who
knows what they're doing.
They'll put you through.
There are a lot more
female mentors now
than there were before.
I had a male mentor.
Don't give up.
-Next question.
Please frame it to a specific
individual on the panel.
-Sure.
Good afternoon.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I actually come from the
world of social justice
practitioners.
I had Transition House, which
is Cambridge's domestic violence
agency.
I come here actually
to figure out
where my work sits between
research and social justice
and other kinds of
corporate information
and popular culture.
And my question is
informed by something
that Mary said in
her discussion, which
was informing her colleagues
to talk at the experience
not the gender.
But what about when the
experience is gender?
-Interesting.
I have to say I wouldn't
have experienced--
because we market stuff.
We market products.
So I haven't had experience with
marketing gender on its own.
There's always a link to a
product, a service, an idea.
I guess the closest thing
I would have is maybe
our campaign for violence
against women, when
we had to speak out about that.
And it still was, what's the
experience of the victim?
And we've had male
victims who were
a subject of domestic
violence, as well as women.
Understand the experience
from their point of view.
How do they want to
be portrayed in this?
Never mind if we had an idea
that would make more money
or get more people aware.
If it disrespects
them or if it makes
them feel ashamed or
humiliated, it's not worth it.
So it'd still go back to
understand that core story
of the individual
that we're trying
to either talk about or
portray what the experience is
of being a victim.
So whether it's a scotch
drinker, et cetera,
the process is the same.
But I haven't had that
much experience with it,
unfortunately.
Not yet.
-And with apologies to those who
will have unanswered questions,
this will have to be
the last question.
-Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Coincidentally, I also worked at
another local domestic violence
services agency,
[INAUDIBLE], which
works with Transition House.
And I'm actually in
development and communications,
but my question's not
really about that.
It's a much more general
question for Christine,
specifically, but I
think anyone might
be able to speak to it, which
is, as a young woman, one
of my big pet peeves is hearing
a lot about these terrible ways
that young women talk, like
upspeak or vocal fry and so on.
And the interesting thing about
that is that I'm getting that
not only from people who are
clearly speaking in bad faith,
but also older female relatives
who very much would describe
themselves as feminists and
think that women my age need
to change the way we present
ourselves or talk in order
to be taken seriously and that
we're disadvantaging ourselves
if we don't.
So my question is about, how
do you navigate the sense
that you should be
listened to no matter
what because what you
have to say is important
and you shouldn't
be looked down upon
for being a woman with
the pragmatic need
to present yourself
in certain ways
in order to be more effective?
And this is both
something that we
face as women in professional
life, as normal people,
and also candidates
face, I'm sure.
-Mm-hm.
Thank you.
Christine?
-Let me just ask a question.
As a young woman, has
anybody ever said--
and I'm not detecting
this with you
at all-- that you have
an upspeak or vocal fry
or anything like that?
Has that been said
to you personally?
-Yes.
Yeah.
-What was your view of that?
For example, did it feel like
something constructive and it's
good to know?
Or did it feel like
criticism and there's nothing
you could do about it?
I'm asking this for a reason
because I have noticed
with younger women the upspeak.
I haven't noticed vocal fry.
This is something new to me
that I've heard just here.
But I have definitely
noticed the upspeak.
And I have actually wondered
about saying something
as a mentor or a colleague,
because I feel like not only
do older women notice it and
maybe don't take it seriously,
but particularly men,
particularly upspeak.
And I'm just curious
to know what's
the most constructive
way if somebody like me,
for example, should notice that?
What do you think?
-So I think this
is hard to answer
because the context in which
it was said to me, actually,
was by my mother, having
casual conversations with her.
And of course we all
code switch in the way
we talk in different
circumstances.
And at work, I talk
differently than I
talk to my mom or my friends.
And I'll probably use
more upspeak and vocal fry
in more casual contexts.
Not on purpose, but
that's just what happens.
So I think that if you're asked
to give feedback on the way
someone talks or presents
themselves, it's always useful.
And also if it's couched
in terms of there's nothing
inherently wrong with
this way of speaking,
but people are jerks and
they're going to judge you.
And this is the way
you navigate within
those oppressive systems.
-Nice.
Good for you.
-I don't know if
that's overly harsh,
but I always found it's
really frustrating when people
are judged for the
style of their speech
rather than the content.
And it happens more
to oppressed people.
-I think of so
many comments that
were made to me
as a young woman,
both from men and
women, particularly men.
And I remember, for example,
going to one meeting
with my male boss.
And I had a title.
I was a research person.
And I had just a pad of paper
ready to-- he was like, don't
come in with a pad of paper.
You're going to look
like a secretary.
And I was like, what
am I supposed to do?
I need to write stuff down.
Hm.
And it was like it
never occurred to me
that coming in with
a pad of paper,
people would perceive me as, the
quote unquote, the "secretary."
So he told me that.
And then I started
to think, well, maybe
I should go out and buy one
of those leather binder things
and put my paper in it so I
look like I have a portfolio.
Would that be helpful?
I mean, I've been
in that situation
where older people had said
things to me as a young woman,
too.
And on some level it
was nice to go, oh,
this is how this is perceived.
Weird.
But OK, either I'm going
to play along or I'm not.
And now that I'm on the other
end and an "older person,"
it's helpful to know what are
constructive ways, if any,
to point that out.
-Please join me in thanking
our distinguished panel.
[APPLAUSE]
-OK.
Well, thank you so much.
Wow.
This was like a dream for me.
I mean, all these panels
of knowledgeable people.
Basically I was given license to
want to learn about this topic.
And we were able to pick these
very thoughtful panelists.
And I can't begin to express
my gratitude towards them.
We're just lucky.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I should let you know that we
have online viewers in the US
from Boston to Seattle, from
New York to Austin, Texas.
Internationally, we
have people viewing
online from [INAUDIBLE],
Colombia, Ankara, Turkey,
Toronto, Canada, Poland,
Bulgaria, France, and the UK.
So that's rather phenomenal.
And I'd like to thank
the people that put
their shoulders to the wheel.
I think that's the
right metaphor.
So Alison Franklin,
Jessica [INAUDIBLE],
Maura Madden, Paul Baron, and
in particular, Becky Wasserman,
who I just can't believe how
much she did to make this
happen.
And I am incredibly
grateful to her.
So to summarize, I
don't think I can really
put it all into thought.
So what I'm going
to do is just use
some of the quotes that were
memorable that I wrote down,
and hopefully it won't
take up too much time.
But these were quotes that
came out of people's mouths,
both in the comedy
session and today.
And they were just
things that I flagged
that seemed to, in a sense,
encapsulate the conference.
So from last night--
"women are fed
so many contradictory
messages that all you can do
is be a robot." "Tragedy
plus time equals comedy."
"Language reifies binary.
This is sufficient
grounds for change."
"Reality is constructed
with language."
"Women have natural
power." "Matrilineal tribes
are more accepting of
third and fourth genders
than patriarchal tribes."
"There is no trans equivalent
of the Academie Francaise
in regard to language change.
It's too important to
rush." "Be shamelessly
flexible with your
language." "If I am passing,
someone else is failing." "When
we center the marginalized,
we become liberated."
"Get closer
to a multi-layered self."
Echoing another
thought-- "Women are
faced with impossible
images in media."
"Allow yourself to
embrace uncertainty."
"An opinion is the short
skirt of the internet."
I like that one.
"The rise of the word
misandry in social media."
"Communication is
incredibly contextual."
From a questioner-- "If
I get policed by men,
I get policed by men, but
secretly supported by women."
"Women, no matter what they
do, it's the wrong choice."
"If your uterus is
functioning, your brain can't."
Ironically.
The term "role ricochet"
which was made up
for this conference.
Thanks, Mary.
"That is way sexier, a
gorilla playing on drums."
Again, context is everything.
"A dad man, this
makes me insane.
So when I go to work, does
this make me a mom dad?"
And the one that Mary had
to tell me to shut up.
"Look at what this does
for resting bitch face."
In terms of run like a girl--
"It means run as fast as you
can." "She's not doing better
because she shouts too much."
"We're not allowed to
laugh too big or too loud."
And I guess I'll
end with this one.
"Are we capable of saying
what we really mean?"
That sounds like a
good one to end it on.
So thank you so
much for attending.
You've been a great audience.
And I think it's been
a great set of panels.
And I've learned
an amazing amount.
So I'm just grateful for all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]